>>Daniel Goleman: If I could
change one thing in education,
it would be making explicit
the now implicit understanding
that the emotional atmosphere
of the classroom matters.
It's not irrelevant; in fact,
it's essential to learning.
And the reason it's essential to
learning, from the scientific point
of view, is that the
emotional centers
of the brain actually can take
over the centers for learning,
and so our attention goes from
what the teacher is saying
to that thing that's upsetting us,
and the failure to understand this,
I think, handicaps
education as a system.
So, if we were to make explicit
the fact that "yes" it matters
that students feel safe; it
matters that students feel calm;
it matters that they're attentive.
And they won't be attentive unless
they're calm and now that we're ready
to learn, we can go ahead.